airline passengers are accounting their
terrifying ordeal after part of their
plane fell off over the Pacific Ocean
video taken inside the jet shows an
engine without its cover the emergency
happened yesterday on United flight 11
75 that runs from San Francisco to
Honolulu Kris Van Cleave is at Reagan
National Airport with how a federal
investigation is now underway Kris good
morning good morning United says it's
pilots followed all the proper safety
protocols to safely land that plane
passengers describe a loud bang and then
shaking and that's when they began to
brace for the worst this is not what you
want to see out your window thousands of
feet above the Pacific Ocean about 40
minutes before landing in Honolulu one
of the engines on United flight 11 75
lost a cover known as a cowling as the
plane rattled through the air pilots
alerted air-traffic controllers on the
ground colonel and that 1175 heavy and
if you haven't already we roll the fire
terms
anxious passengers assume the brace
position as the plane came in for an
emergency landing and cheer when they
finally touch down safely video from the
tarmac shows Fire and Rescue crews
attending to the plane it's right engine
clearly exposed the Boeing triple7 was
carrying 363 passengers and 10 crew
members from San Francisco to Honolulu
United says the plane taxi to the gate
and those aboard to plane normally my
hands and I were just praying because we
had never gone through this experience
and I really thought we were gonna die
relief passengers said they could not
thank the crew enough those pilots
should get an amazing I mean award or
something because we all landed safely
and incredibly smoothly amazing now
there were no injuries the NTSB is
sending a two-person team to investigate
why that engine cowling flew off in
midair the FAA will also investigate
John thanks Chris